well I guess I just I miss talking about
this show too much so even though I
finished up my coverage of Black Mirror
I kind of still want to talk about a
little bit more cuz I really enjoyed the
show so I'm gonna rank all 19 episodes
that have aired to date from bottom to
top so I had considered I'm doing what I
did with the episodes of Firefly and
doing the you know every episode in 10
words or less and then ranking them I
actually found it really hard to do with
this show I don't know if it's because
you know the since everything is
completely different self-contained
episode they're just much harder to sum
up and assess and in a way that feels
like it feels like it works or maybe
it's the tone I don't know I may still
do that at some point but I couldn't
write when I couldn't pull it together
right now but I am gonna give you the
the order of the whole thing enough
preamble starting down at the bottom
number 19 men against fire this one was
probably the one episode of Black Mirror
that I felt didn't do or really try to
do anything that I hadn't seen before or
do it in a way that was excessively
better than what I'd seen before which
pretty much every other episode of black
mayor ever has done it's either done
something that I haven't seen or it's
take something that I've seen in a new
direction or it's just executed at a
higher level than I've ever seen before
this just didn't the whole central
concept of the you know altered
perception of soldiers so that it's
easier for them to to kill their targets
I've seen it done and I've seen it done
acid twists and I've been I felt like
they over foreshadowed it the idea
wasn't that unique the execution of it
wasn't that unique it's still a solid
piece of television that I don't think
black members made a flat-out bad
episode but this is about the only one
that I checked my watch during only time
it happened so moving up one to number
18 we have the Waldo moment I
went back and forth between this or men
against fire being the bottom one
ultimately I gave it to men against fire
and give this one gets a slight edge
because I find the ideas more
interesting here than I did with men
against fire but I do feel this is one
of the rare times where that's it didn't
quite coalesce it didn't quite come
together I feel like the ideas aren't
building on each other the way that most
black my repa sodas they actually do and
while I certainly appreciate it and and
I understand its relevance in terms of
British politics specifically with the
fact that joke candidates are actually
more of a thing over there and like I
get all that I get the context I get
what it's doing I get what it's saying
but it just it's not it's not all
knitting together the the elements of
you know the parody of the political
process the the creator losing control
of his creation the you know the way the
technology and the instant creation of
this animated thing contributes to that
like I they they aren't building on each
other they feel like separate elements
that were just thrown together in the
same story so doesn't quite work for me
number 17 Archangel so now we're pretty
much out of the episodes that I would
argue had fundamental problems with them
and now we're into ones that just didn't
connect with me personally the way that
they were probably intended to because I
know there's plenty of people as I saw
it in my own comments who really took to
Archangel and maybe it's because I never
had the kind of relationship with my own
mother that this character has and my
kid isn't a teenager yet so maybe it's
just that I don't have the frame of
reference that's necessary to really
hook in to this particular episode but I
can watch and I can appreciate it in
terms of you know over monitoring
helicopter parenting you know there is
such thing as protecting your kids too
much but it just didn't quite engage me
on an emotional level which the vast
majority of black mayor episodes do so I
kind of watched it at the end like yeah
yeah that was that was a little out
there and then walked away and it didn't
leave much impact number 16
black mirror which is actually an
episode I enjoy a lot but it's also
probably the episode that is one of the
ones that feels the least like black
mirror and I don't want to put black
Marray in a box too much because I think
different episodes can do completely
different things and what black mirror
is is kind of loose but there is a feel
to black mirror that I feel this likes
because this feels like an episode of
the HBO series of Tales from the Crypt
from when I was much younger cuz it it
has that hole you know between the sort
of feeling like the guy who runs the
museum is like is a bit like the host
taking you through these kind of
horrific stories and then ultimately
ending in a in a bit of a twist of a
comeuppance of a guy paying for his sins
I'm at the very end just it feels and
it's a little bit campy in that way too
especially the pain addict the first
story that it just doesn't it it has a
vibe of a different show that would be
black mirror esque but it it's just a
little too different again not bad by
any means still enjoyable and I enjoyed
it because I watched season four first I
enjoy to even not catching all the
Easter eggs and references to earlier
episodes of the show so that was a good
way to handle that element there there
if you see them you recognize them and
you like them but they're actually not
necessary to recognise to enjoy the
story all the same number fifteen play
test one of the other ones that feels a
little bit less like black mirror in
terms of its presentation because it's
one of the most straightforward episodes
because pretty much as soon as you get
the premise like he's gonna be testing
you know an altered reality horror game
like you know where this is gonna go and
it goes exactly where you expect it to
go it is still well executed though and
this is where we get into that thing
where sometimes what black mirror does
isn't the most unique or surprising
thing in the world but it just does it
at a really high level and I do think
that is the case here I think that
trailer brokers own knowledge of the
video game world and how games actually
work make it way more believable because
so often when video games show up as
plot drivers your plot to Bisons in
shows or movies they will obviously be
written by someone who does not
understand games
how they work or why people play them so
this has that understanding which is a
big part of why it works better than
these sorts of stories usually do but
there is something about that almost
excessive straightforwardness to it that
makes me go that was fine
number fourteen shut up and dance this
is one that I know hit a lot of people
really hard especially with the
revelations towards the end the thing
for me though is that the the
revelations at the end about about our
main character particularly kind of made
me enjoy it less and I mean I know we're
not supposed to enjoy that twist is
supposed to make you feel like you know
kind of gross I think it does but I also
think there was an earlier episode that
kind of did that same thing better for
starters and then it also altered the
nature of what was going on in such a
way that I found it less interesting I
talked about this in more detail in my
review of the episode but in my head how
I thought this was working and why I
thought it was happening I found that
setup that I had in my mind more
intriguing than what it is ultimately
revealed to be going on in terms of why
this particular kid got swept up in all
this so yeah that that bumps it down a
little bit for me but I do get that a
lot of people are really sore to find
this one particular particularly
effectively more so than I did number
thirteen hang the DJ so this is an
episode that I do like but a little bit
like shut up and dance I like what I
thought was going on more than the final
reveal of what actually is going on so
that impacts things a little bit I think
for some people that their opinion of
this might go up or down you know since
it's not the first sort of happy ending
that black mirror episode the black
mirror did that was that was San
Junipero and this came after that but of
course I saw this one first so it was a
very pleasant surprise to get a nice
nice uplifting sweet episode and I liked
the dynamics between the characters I
like sort of showing you know these
relationships and their stuff
and for however long and just see how
they break down some some they fall out
there instantly they know this is wrong
but they're still stuck in it other
times like this is amazing and it's over
like that and and you know and you keep
circling back to someone like what what
could have been there was there
something there I think it captures that
quite well but like I said the one issue
that I have with it is realizing at the
end that the whole thing is a simulation
I don't like as much as what I thought
was happening and what I thought was
happening was that um these people you
know they agree to this program that
they're in that you know says okay now
you're with this person now you're this
for now you're that person and the
program has only focused on the results
giving you that perfect match at the end
and it doesn't care whether or not you
enjoy the process of getting there
because a computer doesn't care about
your feelings an algorithm doesn't give
a damn as to whether or not you're
enjoying this as long as it gets the
right final result and I liked that that
seemed to be at play for the internal
logic of the simulation but then to find
out that it's a simulation kind of
alters what was going on in the first
place in a way that I isn't bad but I
just don't like as much as what I
thought was the case so that's why it's
not higher than venue number 12
crocodile this was the first episode of
black mirror that just left me feeling
drained and emotionally beaten up and
there was I thought it was gonna land
higher on the list before I came to
ordering the whole thing but we are now
at this point getting into episodes that
did have real serious impact on me in
one way or another and it's more of a
question in terms of their ranking how
how much that impact hit me and sort of
how it was panned out and spread out
across the episode so this one I mean
it's it's watching the downward spiral
and it is it is well played out I think
ultimately the reason I have it lowers
just because what I'm comparing it on in
terms of assembling of the story and and
the the way it goes about everything I
just think it's not quite at the same
execution level of most of the stuff
that I have listed higher and I think it
might it's sort of
means on just the lurid nosov what is
going on for its shock value rather than
sort of more the intellectual concepts
being terrifying which is sort of my
preferred version of Black Mirror for
the most part number eleven nosedive now
this was an episode that did not always
connect for me there's basically a
stretch in the middle where I'm not
gonna say it lost me but I wasn't nearly
as engaged but that first chunk and then
the end those got me so much that it's
it ends up higher than I think I thought
I was going to put it because I did kind
of disengage from that little bit a
little bit but when it is establishing
the way the society works the way social
media is driving our actions and the way
that we alter ourselves and who we are
and how we behave based on that and the
seeking of that approval yes somebody
with a attempting to build a social
media following that that hit close to
home and then ending on this really
bizarrely
uplifting note that still that didn't
feel like it undermined how Black Mirror
is like I hesitate to call it a happy
ending but it's like yeah that feels
right okay top ten time next up
metal head now I know this is an episode
that a lot of fans seems to not like
particularly well and I think it's just
because it is just such a departure in
terms of how black Mary usually tends to
be now Bera mine again I saw a season
four first so I saw this before I had as
firm a sense in my head of what black
mirror is supposed to be so I didn't
have those same expectations that this
may or may not have failed to meet and
maybe I would have had a different
opinion of it if I'd watch the whole
thing in order but I really liked this
episode and I like the departures it
takes and I think the way that it shot
doing it in black and white is really
well done I do
I like the dogs I like the simplicity of
them this thing is built for efficiency
only and it's not you know there's not
this big bulky thing to look
intimidating you scare it doesn't need
to it's just built to be a really
effective hunting killing machine
that's all it has to do so I I like all
of that it's really tense
and it's it's heroin honestly and I know
a lot of people like the last image of
the fact that all that they were after
we're teddy bears seems to throw a lot
of people off for me it feels perfect
because it really drives home how
hopeless the world is for whatever
reason it's in the state that it's in
because these people were willing to
risk their lives for something that
innocuous because that's how little hope
there is in this world that it's worth
risking your life just to give a sliver
of of hope to a dying child like that's
bleak that's really bleak and it felt
right and I think part of the other
thing is people got annoyed because it's
not as well explained in terms of how we
got here and why things are the way they
are as black mirror usually is but for
me for this story
it works number-9 hated in the nation
killer robot bees this should be dumb
this should be campy this should be
laughable and it's not and again it's
tapping into that an understanding of
social media and social media mentality
and the way people can be and also
acknowledging the different
rationalizations and justifications that
people have for being for lack of a
better term [ __ ] on the on the
internet you know there are people who
do it because they think it's funny
there are people who do it because they
honestly think the person they're
directing their anger towards is a
horrible person they're doing it for a
lark they're you know some motivations
are more inherently you know malicious
than others but it's still wrong and
this sort of meaning out this this
retribution of it doesn't matter why you
did it you did it and now you're gonna
pay for it that was I think it was just
really well actually here I thought the
bill to it was nice and you know like I
said the robot bee should have been
laughable but I think they were well
executed and became they worked better
and better and better the long
the episode kept going and they were
used more like man okay yeah this works
number eight the entire history of you
another good one sort of drilling into
the fact that there are some things
about the way that we are wired as
people that we would be better not
quote-unquote improving that because
humans don't have perfect memory we're
not built to have perfect memory and
honestly as social animals it's a bad
thing for us to have perfect memory
because so much of our moving forward in
life is not being able to go through our
memories and find and go through
everything with a fine-tooth comb but
instead you know remembering oh it was
more or less like this and then you move
on but when you can go back and
literally scroll through exactly what
was said see exactly we saw again here
the exact words that people said to you
you become first of all you become
overly obsessed with the past and then
in addition to that you lose the the
ability to frankly lie to yourself or to
ignore details which we do as humans and
we filter we ignore we sometimes because
we figure stuff doesn't matter sometimes
for the sake of our own ego our own
ability to live our daily lives we don't
notice some stuff and going back and
then starting to notice it and notice
everything because you keep going back
over and over and over again
watching how that impacts people filter
through this couple is just really
well-executed and a good demonstration
of how not necessarily that technology
is scary about how some things that
technology now allows us to do is that
something that we as a species can
actually cope with properly yeah number
seven white bear so this is the episode
that I think did what shop and dance
tried to do with its twist ending better
in terms of having a character that we
have been with sympathized with been
rooting for and find out that they are a
terrible person or that or that day at
some point they're like did something
truly atrocious and
sort of feeling dirty for having rooted
for them but then this one also adds
that extra layer on top of that of you
still can't quite abandon feeling sorry
for her as you realize she's just gonna
go through this over and over and over
again and these people are taking this
weird sick enjoyment out of what they're
calling justice but this this seems
wrong and yet what she did and what she
was involved in was so terrible it it
does result in a wonderful conflict I
think for me internally but also between
people because the comments section on
that particular episode when I reviewed
it was probably the most divided in
terms of how people felt about the
episode not whether they liked it or not
but whether they thought what happened
to her was acceptable or not and there
were and thankfully was kept play and
nobody was a was a jerk to anybody else
because I have awesome subscribers but
there was a fair number of people who
like this is horrible doesn't matter
what she did this should never happen to
anyone there were other people who said
it doesn't matter what they do to or
anything is too good for her I have no
moral qualms about what's going on here
and seeing that divide between audiences
to me just points to how well this works
number six the national anthem man that
is a heck of a way to kick off that that
is putting something really
uncomfortable and making you see it like
we're not just gonna play like this is
what's going on here and it's not like
it necessary going this is what Blackmer
is about but it's saying if you can't
handle this there's the door and I don't
blame anybody who saw this episode and
one bit show is not for me and I think
that was very much the intention of it
and it comes in and it hits hard and
it's darkly funny but then it also
doesn't let the inherent ickiness of
what is going on go away completely
either and I think ultimately this
episode is made by the last few seconds
the little extra bits that we see during
the closing credits because after
everything that's gone on you know
watching people so
the Prime Minister go against him not
want him to do this want him to do this
watch whether they want to or not
whether they are grinning disgusted you
know all these reactions that all that
eventually fades and doesn't matter and
ultimately didn't seem to impact him but
then he gets in private with his wife
and she cannot even look at him because
the impact on the world at large the
social media sphere almost anything I'm
not gonna say anything but almost
anything that you could do for you know
whether it is makes you look good or
makes you look awful it's gonna be
short-lived because the world moves on
but the people immediately close to you
don't just move on because it's not a
fleeting thing for them they have to
deal with it she has to look at him
every day and be confronted with what it
was that happened what it was that he
did and she can't and that may or may
not be fair in terms of you know his
reasons for doing it and and and
anything else but that's the reality the
world can choose to forget or ignore
what happened she can't she's confronted
with it every time she sees him and
those last few seconds really bump this
up a lot number five be right back
examining grief is a tricky thing to do
because it can very easily become
maudlin and melodramatic and laughable
but it's not here it's handled with a
with a very high degree of honesty the
way that we try to hold on to what we've
lost and we think boy if I could just
have one more day than what we think we
would give what we would be willing to
do to have that and to watch it play out
and to watch it all start to to unravel
for her because and and it's very much
the same with you know memorabilia and
again I think it's a good commentary on
on social media because thanks to social
media
once someone is gone we can look through
their Instagram feeds their Facebook
post and all the stuff and feel like we
can touch them again in a way but that's
not a complete picture because we self
edit there are parts of ourselves we
don't show there and it can be a it can
be a solve it can be a bomb at first for
a little bit but then over time it's you
realize everything that's missing
everything that made up who this person
is that you can't get again that you
can't get access again that no number of
you know old post shared memories there
are things you cannot recapture and that
gap
it just gets wider over time until
what's missing is all you see and then
finally her but also her not being able
to let go and up he goes into the Attic
with the with the memorabilia with the
things that you can't let go up but you
can't look at anymore because it hurts
too much
it rings really true it's a great
examination of grief it's a great
episode number for this this was an
episode I did not know how to evaluate
this in terms of this ranking because
this one Oh God white Christmas this one
destroyed me I mean crocodile did get to
me pretty harshly and I and I mentioned
that this episode wrecked me and I
couldn't even I couldn't even talk about
it properly without choking up if you if
you didn't see that that review that I
did for that ia was it was hard to even
talk about this episode which certainly
speaks to its effectiveness but I did
wonder you know is that blinding me to
possible issues with it since
wasn't necessarily a pleasant emotional
experience do I want to put that high or
low but it was astoundingly effective
for what it was trying to do at least
with me it was and yeah I have to put it
this high because like I said it just
destroyed me
that last segment finding out about but
yeah not just the ending finding out
about what happened to the girl
everything leading up to that because I
felt bad for I felt bad for the guy who
thought it was his kid and then watching
that all unravel and just seeing it and
in that oh god it was awful was
horrifying and it hit me in a way that
not a lot of things do because there
there are plenty of things that can make
me cry either for good reasons or
batteries but things that actually leave
me broken which this this episode did
that's a real short list and this is on
it number three
USS Callister first episode I ever saw
and definitely still one of my favorites
I love everything going on in here I
love the balance of elements I like to
look and the kam penis that this set of
the Callister itself has I love the
insight into daily as a character I love
the way that these people who have been
trapped inside here are coping or trying
to cope you know it's and the way that
non-player characters view a player
character in a video game when they know
they're in a video game and there's
stuck at the whims of this guy who they
can't stand but it's here for him and
they have to go by that and and the the
existential thoughts that it makes you
think and again sort of coming back to
themes about like look you can
rationalize it as they're just ones and
zeros they're not really people but this
is still awful atrocious behavior and ya
have to wonder to a certain degree but
it hooks you in with them it makes you
care about them it's funny at moments
where it could really use a bit of
levity it ends on a one of the more
upbeat notes the black mare could end
and almost triumphant but yet
undercutting and slavery by reminding
everyone like yeah they're just kind of
out on the internet right now
the Internet's kind of awful let's not
forget that so not being overly
triumphant about it it's this is this is
a fun episode of Black Mirror there are
not many of those but this is one number
215 million merits this might be in my
mind the quintessential black mayor
episode in terms of having honestly a
lot going on but it all feels so
complete the way and the way that it
comments on how people we spin our
wheels for rewards that aren't even real
for intangible things that don't matter
and how we get lured and you know I just
carrot dangled in front of us you know
these impossible dreams like that's
ridiculous and then even getting that
dream it can easily be a nightmare and
yet at the same time after that amazing
break down performance from Daniel Kuya
holding that Google has to his throat
that ultimately even though he knows
system is wrong it chews people out and
it homogenizes everything the offer is
too tempting the way that corporations
co-opt anger outrage that's directed at
them and they still find a way to cash
in on it and it's just so it speaks so
much to the human experience in the 21st
century and and sticks it in just this
slight future slight sci-fi world and it
feels just it like everything means
something needs everything I've got my
one nitpick about it but I talked about
that in the in the episode review proper
and honestly that unique to me it's not
a fault of the story but I am gonna
address one thing here because a lot of
people asked in the comments on my
review
that episode whether I thought that at
the very end when he looks out the
window and he's seeing this forest
whether that is just a bigger screen or
if that's actually a force cuz it seemed
to be a lot of going back and forth a
lot of people seem to think it was just
a bigger screen I actually believe it's
both I believe that is a real forest out
there but he can't go out and experience
it so he traded his being surrounded by
screens that you know show him fake
things to being able to see something
real but still being unable to interact
with it still being unable to experience
it directly that is my belief it is it
is a gilded cage and it's one that he
chose and it's one he is continuing to
choose because he keeps putting out the
episodes of this thing and it's yeah it
embodies how selling out happens to
people who you wouldn't think that what
happened to so well that's great but we
got number one and I'm sure some of you
have been taking off on the list so you
already know what it is let's get to it
San Junipero this is this is the episode
I have gone back and re-watched the most
since having finished the run of black
mirror and it is such a wonderful
touching experience that still feels
like black mirror yeah the way that it
manages to be touching and sweet and
uplifting and joyous while still feeling
like it belongs in the world where all
this horrible stuff happens it's just
wonderful it is amazing and touching and
uplifting and the chemistry between
these two women is astounding and just
depicting how each is afraid of you know
what their future might be and afraid of
trying to be with each other for
different reasons and
wondering you know do they see or are
they actually understanding what I'm
putting out there and and capturing that
hesitation on both sides and it is just
wonderful it's glorious and it's
becoming a bit of comfort food
television for me at this point where
it's not like the world is all sunshine
and rainbows but even in even in a world
where things are fake things aren't real
it's all an illusion you can still find
real connections and real happiness and
relate to people in a way that is
genuine regardless of how artificial
trappings are how fake the way that you
found each other is doesn't matter
because the connection is real and that
is beautiful and wonderful that makes it
my favorite episode of Black Mirror so
that's my ranking for the entirety of
Black Mirror at least until we get more
episodes which cannot come soon enough
as far as I'm concerned what is your
ranking I mean if you want to do all 19
you can do that if you want to just give
a top 5 or a top and a bottom however
you want to do whatever your thoughts
are drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it there's so many ways
to follow me or support me on patreon if
you feel like it and they're links for
all that stuff is down in the
description so until next time this
council's adjourned
[Music]
you
[Applause]
[Music]